[Musique]
il ferait de gala opposera mardan
peugeot à poissy ultimate battle masters
c'est l'une des compétitions émergentes
du breakdance cette année c'est une
équipe française qui a remporté le titre
c'était assez rude parce que c'était sûr
du temps lui minutes 10 minutes 10
minutes c'est ça demande beaucoup de
temps beaucoup d'énergie surtout que
on n'était pas préparé à ça mais
on a su quand même
bien bien relever la pente et on a pu
gagner cette compétition et on est très
fier de moi et mon équipe une belle
performance dans le niveau était élevé
avec des équipes venues du monde entier
parce qu'on a pu voir ce soir ça fait
partie de l'excellence mondiale
que ce soit le continent européen le
continent africain le continent
américain voilà ils étaient tous
représentés c'est actuellement ce qui se
fait quasiment de mieux pour encadrer
les athlètes un jury de prestige jury
que j'ai choisi sévèrement à la crème au
niveau de hauts niveaux de débits beau
et français on n'a eu qu'à lille qui est
champion de france on a eu l'idée
qu'est-ce qui est triple champion du
monde et on a eu chaud saute une figure
emblématique du bboying français et qui
est aussi champion de france donc voila
et vice champion du monde du côté des
moins de 16 ans l'italien bboy dunger a
gagné la finale face au fond c'est le
qui je suis un peu déçu d'avoir perdu en
finale mais là je vais m'entraîner pour
gagner la prochaine fois peut-être le
break dance et ont désormais une
discipline olympique ultimate battle
master souhaite s'inscrire dans les
tournois préparatoires en vue de paris